why
or do
the comms and pr folks sometimes
kill the heart and soul of
of the magic that makes a company or is
that is that wrong to say
give me an example
i will say the spirit of the example
which is
uh it feels like often the jobs of of
communications
is to provide caution
it almost it almost works together with
legal to say
yeah we should probably should not
say this we'll probably let's be careful
let's be careful now that makes sense
except
in this modern world
authenticity
is extremely valuable
and revealing the beauty that is in the
engineering the beauty of the
the ideas the chaos of the ideas i think
requires
throwing caution to the wind to some
degree i agree and
i just find that
boy i mean it's really so to to push
back on myself i think it's an extremely
difficult job because people hold you
responsible as you're doing
communications
when you take risks right um
uh and especially when they fail so like
the it's a difficult job so i understand
why people become cautious but to me
communications is about taking big risks
and throwing caution to the wind at his
best because your job
is to communicate
in the long term
communicate the genius the the joy
the the the genius of the products right
and that sometimes is a tension with
caution sorry so i i
uh because i've gotten a chance to meet
a lot of very interesting people and
interesting engineering teams and so on
i look at what they're doing and i look
at what's being communicated
and it's just there's a mismatch because
the communication is a lot more boring
it's like there's something very
like
just straight up boring about the way
they're communicating because of caution
okay
and you have just teed me up or another
diatribe okay i'm gonna get on my i'm
gonna get on my podium here yes please
uh
it all comes out of the leader
if the leader doesn't know how to
storytell or the leader doesn't know how
to do bold storytelling
then
you get even more con conservatism from
the pr and communications folks
because they're always so if you have a
not a bold leader
they they're always going to be a filter
right they're always going to try to
smooth things out and take off the rough
edges and try so they're going to be
even more if you have a conservative
messaging leader you're going to have
even a more conservative
communications department why because
they want to keep their jobs
okay it's really simple yes they got to
keep their jobs if they say one wrong
thing yeah it could be the end of it so
if you have very conservative leader
they're going to be even more
conservative if you have a bold leader
there will be oh they'll always take a a
little more conservative bent but you're
still going to have bold communications
yeah that's brilliant okay so it starts
with the leader now
that said
when you
you
you think about the messages and the joy
and revealing things right
many of these leaders
don't tell great stories
so what we do at future shape our
investment firm
is we take those scientists all and the
great minds and everything and what do
we surround them with
marketing and communication people and
storytellers to give them the confidence
to tell a much broader story
about the impacts of what they're
creating and how big the global change
can be with those technologies because
usually they don't those leaders who
created those technologies they don't
really know how to communicate really
well and they don't feel very
comfortable in how they speak yeah so
it's interesting because stories and i'm
a huge fan of stories
have you ever read the book story no by
robert mckee
you should read this and this is what i
read when it's 26.
story by robert mckee and it's a book
all about
the
waste due script writing
the prototypical
types of scripts drama comedy and how
it's been shown over you know
millennia how these stories are done
it's it's a fascinating thing and it
gives you an insight
to and it's it's written for you know
obviously hollywood and and and movies
and things like that but it's incredibly
useful for what we do um as designers
and engineers and and technology piano
leaders there's some aspect in this
modern day where you know this podcast
and so on
um
what i love is the humans behind the
story too so some part of the story is
the human beings
um
so humor
drama
heartbreak hope emotions emotions
that's not just about us a painting a
beautiful story that's flawless
it's uh vulnerability yep it's uh you
know being a dreamer like over promising
and then
uh failing
real life so changing your mind
realizing sort of just the whole of it
and then also being like uh depending of
course where your personality is
um embracing the full richness and the
complexity of the personality of the
leader or the different people involved
i mean that that's all part of it like
you can't just present this
beautiful always pleasantville view of a
product there has to be
this um this humanity that's part of it
the the full roller coaster of the
humanity which i i think is uh been very
difficult for companies to embrace right
not sure why
i'm not maybe it's just an old school
way of doing things like people think
you know that we present a facade
and uh you know we generate the story
and we tell the story as opposed to sort
of um well we learn especially in the
technical world we present the story as
it's faster it's smaller it's longer
battery life it's it's bits and numbers
and
you know and and metrics
that that resonates
sure with other geeks
what resonates with the the the you know
the planet
it's all emotions right and if you can
bring a great emotional story but with a
great rational story at the same time
why you should do this and it's like oh
my god you bring that superpower that
joy
then it all hangs and there's personal
drama too like
the human right the here's the pain i
had remember that thing
and like i mean just i mean just you
know uh you're
you're obviously
this extremely
well-known human being that's behind a
lot of these
uh great inventions of the technology
world but you're also just a human being
you have a clearly
uh
like a distinct personality that comes
through the like your eyes light up just
the way you communicate is that's you
um
some people are more stoic some people
are sure like uh elon is
you know all over the place the chaos uh
steve jobs
you know there's a very i mean it's hard
to put into words that can be poetic and
so on but there's a very distinct it
comes on you know that personality right
there that's not just the product that's
something else too correct and like you
have to reveal that a little bit and
allow people to reveal that a little bit
and just let them be
themselves well
look
why why do i think your podcast is so
amazing because you are yourself
you talk about yourself you bring your
emotions into it and you don't modulate
it
you you're you
right
it comes through it's it's true it feels
right you are you you that you you dress
the way you want to dress you say this
is me and this is all of me and you and
you become vulnerable right much easier
to do a podcast like that than run a
very large company correct where a lot
of people would feel the pain if you
make if you say something stupid right
if you so um there's a it's much more
easy to be afraid right and be careful
so
but nevertheless the same applies
um authenticity and risk taking is is is
the only way unfortunately
uh to be successful in the long term
you